ces images témoignent de l'ampleur des
dévastations barbuda subi de plein fouet
la fureur d'irma dans les premières
heures du 6 septembre
comme après un bombardement mourad on
l'a laissé derrière lui que des
squelettes de maisons caudrine tonnes
l'unique village de barbuda n'est plus
aujourd'hui qu'un champ de ruines avec
ces bâtisses éventré et ses toitures
souffle et pulvérisé pour échapper à la
colère du monstrueux cyclone la
population a dû se réfugier au fin fond
des maisons voire des armoires
solidement agrippée pour ne pas être
aspiré par la violence des vents comme
la seule victime de ce cataclysme
une enfant de deux ans ce que jésus est
ce que j'ai entendu je n'avais entendu
nulle pa je n'allais jamais vu non plus
ailleurs les vents soufflent à plus de
300 350 peut-être même 400 km heure une
femme a raconté que quand sa toiture est
partie elle est allée chez un voisin
vingt minutes après le toit s'est aussi
envolé elle est allée chez un autre
voisin et ainsi de suite de maison en
maison
jusqu'à ce qu'elle se dise que cette
solution ne fonctionnait pas et qu'elle
essaye alors de prendre le chemin du
refuge le plus proche
on n'imagine pas le niveau de
traumatismes forme
[Musique]
ce paysage de désolation est restée
telle quelle elle depuis l'ouragan
car toute la population a été évacuée en
catastrophe vers antigue l'île soeur
distante de 40 kilomètres et qui forme
avec barbe ou d'un état
seuls sont restés sur place les animaux
domestiques les chiens les chats ainsi
que le bétail laissé derrière des
animaux des appareils livrés à eux mêmes
sur cette île déserte et est placé sous
surveillance policière et militaire
nous avons treize soldats ici en ce
moment nous faisons des patrouilles de
sécurité la nuit et durant la journée
nous offrons notre assistance on
transporte des gens ce qu'ils collectent
des affaires donc nous devons avoir sur
l'île un camion opérationnel à tout
moment afin de s'assurer qu'il n'est pas
le pillage ou de personnes qui
s'approchent parce qu'elles pourraient
venir en parler c'est totalement
dévastés comme vous pouvez le voir c'est
inhabitables en grande partie il y à
quelques animaux morts aux alentours
beaucoup de constructions en ruine des
eaux stagnantes donc ce n'est pas
l'idéal
nous devons nous assurer que tout le
monde quitte l'île durant la nuit
sur cette île aussi grande et plates que
marie galante des débris en tous genres
ont été projetés comme des missiles à
des kilomètres à la ronde des
contenaires ont même été déplacés par la
force des vents ou de l'eau la marée de
tempête a été violente
[Musique]
il y en a aussi changé la couleur de
lille en balayant la végétation et en
remodelant les contours de l'île
[Musique]
un paysage de désolation bien éloignée
du décor paradisiaque que connaissent
les touristes et les visiteurs
[Musique]
avant le cyclone lille était fréquenté
pour ces kilomètres de plages de sable
blanc et pour sa tranquillité
une beauté naturelle prisé des stars et
des têtes couronnées barbuda était dans
les années 90 la destination favorite de
la défunte princesse diana
c'était son repaire pour des vacances
discrètes notamment sur cette plage du
sud de l'île qui porte aujourd'hui son
nom
elle descendait dans cet hôtel dont la
propriété était rachetée l'an dernier
par l'acteur américain robert de niro
mais toute la structure a été ravagée
comme tous les hôtels de barbuda l'île
comptait moins d'une centaine de
chambres destinées surtout à une
clientèle fortunée
nous allons reconstruire barbuda ici
c'est le paradis
les gens sont sympathiques cette beauté
naturelle cette gentillesse naturelle
qui émane des gens c'est important pour
notre tourisme
bien sûr nous avons les fameuses
frégates de renommée mondiale
ces oiseaux marins ainsi que le
sanctuaire qui est site superbe où les
touristes peuvent aller les contempler
donc par mme houda est très important
pour le tourisme d'antibes guardi
coupée du monde après le passage de
l'oeil d'irma sur barbuda les autorités
antiguaise ne découvre l'ampleur de la
catastrophe que dans l'après-midi du 6
septembre après un survol en hélicoptère
du premier ministre abasourdis par les
dévastations gas en branle en 10 h
d'emblée l'évacuation de la population
vrille ont évacué la population de
barbuda nous examinerons la situation et
nous prendrons une décision sur le plan
qui sera exactement arrêté nous avons
apporté un téléphone satellite que nous
laissons ici car le système de
communication est entièrement détruit
installé en thing cet homme a été l'un
des premiers à atteindre les côtes de
barbuda après l'ouragan hilary fuller
spécialiste des randonnées touristiques
en bateau a pu mettre rapidement son
embarcation à l'eau dans la matinée du 6
septembre à son arrivée sur l'île c'est
une population sous le choc qui
l'accueille pas évident qu'ils étaient
dans le déni sur ce qui s'est passé
vous savez quelquefois quand vous
regardez quelqu'un qui vient d'avoir un
accident ils essaient de redémarrer la
voiture véhicules et détruit mais les
seuils de le démarrer pour aller chez
lui c'est comme ça qu'ils étaient oui
nous pouvons rester ici j'ai de l'eau je
suis bien j'ai pris seulement 17
personnes non seize personnes la
première fois personne ne voulait partir
donc j'ai pris cette personne et je suis
revenu
nous sommes retournés à saint john la
capitale d'antibes c'est le branle bas
de combat face à la menace d'un autre
cyclone le chef de gouvernement décrète
rapidement l'état d'urgence à barbuda
des pouvoirs spéciaux qui lui permettent
d' ordonner l'évacuation de toute la
population
lille est sur la trajectoire de
l'ouragan josé qui ne cesse de se
renforcer
tous les barbus dhien doivent partir en
moins de deux jours en plus d'un
désastre naturel
les autorités d'antiques doivent gérer
une crise humanitaire
cette petite île a été dévasté
95% des structures sont détruites et à
cause d'un autre cyclone qu'approche
d'antigue dans les prochaines heures
voire demain on évacue car si on reste
ici
la situation peut être pire donc on
évacue temporairement vers en tig
une noria d'embarcations commence à
effectuer des allers retours entre
barbuda et antigua
le temps presse mais la solidarité est
jouable
des propriétaires de bateaux privés sont
venus à la rescousse pour évacuer les
habitants de l'île il faut une heure
trente pour effectuer la traversée sur
ce bateau 106 personnes s'embarque avec
quelques effets personnels
je suis content de partir
bar honda est dévastée il faudra du
temps pour reconstruire au ballet de
petits avions et des hélicoptères
assurent aussi l'évacuation sur la piste
de caudry m'etonne qui a été dégagé
les infrastructures sont sérieusement
endommagés mais le personnel assure
comme il peut les rotations pour ces
sinistrés dont le calvaire n'est pas
terminé
je suis venu j'ai vu beaucoup de peur
dans le regard des enfants qui ont été
évacuées ou qui vont arriver à antigue
mais les anti gays sont mobilisés pour
bien les accueillir ils ne doivent avoir
aucune crainte
[Rires]
les toitures sont tombés donc maintenant
mme évacuent vers antilles et on espère
le meilleur
si l'ouragan ne détruit pas davantage on
reviendra et on commencera à
reconstruire
mais l'évacuation de la population prend
plus de temps que prévu
les pilotes des reculs vénézuélien
dépêché antique par nicolas maduro
viennent à la rescousse avec leur c-130
l'aéroport de barbuda étant
impraticables pour ses avions de
transport militaire l'atterrissage se
fait à la pointe sud de barbuda coco
pointe sur l'herbe de cette courte piste
tracée pour la clientèle d'un hôtel de
la zone
au sol les barbus bien pu embarquer
patiente en plein soleil
ils ont fait le trajet comme ils le
pouvaient jusqu'à cette côte sud de
l'île c'est le cas de cet homme dont la
famille a déjà été transférée antilles
il va pouvoir embarquer à bord de
l'avion vénézuélien
les forces armées antiguaise organisé
canalise l'évacuation
quand une arme le capitaine a demandé
100 personnes avec chacun deux bagages
maintenant on ajoute 20 de plus on a les
noms inscrits sur un papier selon les
instructions que le capitaine m'a donné
ce matin il y a donc maintenant vingt
personnes supplémentaires pour aller en
tig et chaque 15 minutes plus d'une
centaine de personnes montent dans
l'avion pour aller en tig
[Musique]
si nous n'avions pas cet appareil du
venezuela nous serions dépendants de nos
bateaux de nos petites embarcations et
du ferry qui ont aussi évacué des genres
hier mais cet avion prend 120 personnes
en voyage
la population de barbuda et d'à peu près
mille six cents personnes entre 200 et
400 personnes sont parties hier et même
dans la soirée avec le ferry d'autres ce
matin mais l'avion a transporté au final
900 personnes aujourd'hui
une fois à bord les sinistrés sont
invités à s'asseoir à même le plancher
de l'appareil l'angoissé se lit sur les
visages
après avoir subi la colère du vent tous
ces barbus dhien sont contraints à
l'exode
un départ vers un avenir incertain en
300 ans d'occupation
c'est la première fois que l'île se vide
totalement de ses habitants
après un petit quart d'heure de vol
c'est l'arrivée à l'aéroport d'anti jeu
ne sait ni quand ni où ni comment je
retournerai parce qu'on nous a rien dit
si on retourne ou pas et parce que
toutes les d'écraser tout ça est
démoralisant il y a plus d'emploi
l'endroit où je travaillais sait d'où
nous sommes partis
coco boys et c'est dévastée dès leur
descente d'avion les barbus dhien sont
pris en charge par les autorités
dalmat comme tous les autres réfugiés
prennent place dans ses autobus ils sont
amenés dans un centre avant d'être
orientés vers un refuge ou une famille
d'accueil c'est dans les faubourgs de
saint john que nous retrouvons le
lendemain d'alma il a rejoint son épouse
et ses sept garçons arrivés par bateau
un jour avant lui cette famille
nombreuse et hébergé par cette
antiguaise au grand coeur il ne
s'agissait pas de se demander s'il
pouvait venir
c'était juste une question devenait et
apporter ce que vous avez si vous n'avez
rien il n'y a pas de problème parce que
le seigneur est grand j'ai deux garçons
là 22 ans et l'autre 16 ans eux ils ont
sept garçons donc nous partageons nous
cuisinons sa femme cuisine je cuisine
les garçons cuisine et il nettoie aussi
elle est comme une soeur pour moi et
pour ma famille je pense qu'il préfère
être chez eux
mais qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
barbu d'année plus habitable pour le
monde donc nous devons rester ici et
jusqu'à ce que nous puissions faire
comme après l'éruption de la soufrière
de montserrat beaucoup d'antillais ont
ouvert leurs portes et leurs coeurs aux
sinistrés la famille d'allemands occupe
trois chambres de la maison mais le
moral est au plus bas
tous savent qu'ils s'installent dans un
provisoire et une précarité après a duré
cet homme de 49 ans vivaient de la pêche
et de son métier de serveur dans un
hôtel de barbuda il doit se recomposer
un environnement de vie et ce n'est pas
facile
vous dormez bien non je n'y arrive pas
et le lit et confortable ça n'a rien à
voir avec le dit mais l'esprit est resté
sur l'île je les laissais là bas c'est
aussi le cas de votre épouse oui c'est
pareil pour ma femme comme pour les
enfants aussi à la cuisine les femmes ça
fait l'absence d'électricité et d'eau
depuis le passage de l'ouragan est en
bas à compliquer la tâche
une bonne partie des provisions contenu
dans le réfrigérateur partent à la
poubelle en s'occupant de la vaisselle
et du repas betty tente de faire bonne
figure comme une nouvelle maison pour
moi monsieur je sais que chez moi ce
n'est pas ici mais nous ne sommes pas en
condition pour que nous puissions
retourner maintenant nous devons nous
faire à cette nouvelle vie à ce nouveau
départ
en fait tout recommencer parce qu'à
barbe d'un aîné a plus de travail plus
d'électricité plus d'eau et n'y a plus
rien si beaucoup de bars bodian ont de
la famille ou des amis pour les héberger
plus de 500 d'entre eux ont dû être
installés dans des refuges temporaires
comme ici dans les locaux du stade de
cricket d'anti d'autres réfugiés sont
hébergés dans ce centre de formation des
enseignants
le dernier étage est réservé aux hommes
où des lits de camps ont été installés
ou premier ce sont les femmes et les
enfants
au total ici plus de cent personnes sont
logées dans ses dortoirs
vingt personnes quelque chose comme ça
c'est dans cette pièce
vous connaissez tous le monde tout le
monde rit on se connaît tous et barbuda
cette atmosphère de famille et un
réconfort pour cette femme qui a perdu
sa maison
une promiscuité qui l'aide à surmonter
ses angoisses et sa détresse
son fils de 21 ans est aussi logés dans
ce refuge mais il faudra du temps pour
soigner les blessures avant j'aimais me
sentais vraiment pas bien
je pleurais pourquoi parce que vous avez
tout perdu oui et parce que je n'avais
nulle part où aller
je n'ai plus d'emplois vous avez perdu
votre emploi
je travaille à l'école et il n'y a plus
rien à faire pour l'instant les
barbadiens peuvent compter sur la
générosité des anti gay pour survivre
les aides les dons affluent ici des
vêtements et des chaussures de toutes
tailles sont à la disposition des
sinistrés
je remercie dieu
j'ai trouvé ce dont j'ai besoin des
pantalons des t-shirts je suis habillé
je remercie tous ceux qui nous
soutiennent vous trouvez tout ce que
vous voulez oui tout ce que je veux des
chaussures des vêtements des serviettes
vraiment où je suis satisfait je suis
content
mais certains réfugiés ne penseront
retour
c'est le cas de cet homme de 59 ans la
menace de l'ouragan josé s'étant
éloignés il estime qu'il est temps de
rentrer nous voulons rentrer chez nous
barbu d'assécher nous nous les barbus
dhien nous vivons très près la nature
maintenant le cyclone est passé
ils ont décidé de maintenir les gens ici
pourquoi c'est la question que je me
pose pourquoi c'est une question
difficile
il n'ya plus d'infrastructures de base à
barbuda plus d'hôpital plus de services
de santé plus de casernes de pompiers
plus de postes de police plus d'eau plus
d'électricité pas de téléphone
donc tous les efforts seront faits pour
restaurer ses services aussi vite que
nous le pouvons mais je suppose que
temps que ses services ne seront pas
opérationnels
les gens devront rester quelque temps
la première réunion du parlement après
l'ouragan igor m'a confirme les craintes
de séjours prolongés réuni en session
spéciale afin de ratifier l'état
d'urgence le premier ministre doit on en
profite pour dévoiler ses objectifs pour
barbuda prioriser la remise en état des
infrastructures et construire 200
maisons en six mois
pour cela il a lancé des appels aux dons
car l'ardoisé s'annonce très lourde
le chef de gouvernement s'engagent à
disposer d'un quart des fonds
nécessaires dès le mois prochain
monsieur le président je garantie qu'en
moins de 30 jours mon gouvernement
pourra collecter 50 millions de dollars
je le garantis je lui souhaite le
meilleur au nom du peuple de barbuda est
ce que ces fonds seront définitivement
nécessaire pour pouvoir au moins
commencer la restauration dans un rapide
ça va nous coûter plus de 200 millions
de dollars états unis un minimum pour
reconstruire leur bouddha toutes les
infrastructures sont endommagés 95% des
maisons sont détruites en fait marc
bouddha est en ce moment un champ de
ruines et malheureusement cela n'a
nécessité d'énormes ressources
financières les ressources qui sont à la
charge de l'état
nous allons devoir solliciter
l'assistance d'autres gouvernements
d'autres pays
pour se relever les barbadiens ne
peuvent compter que sur l'état anti gay
car sur l'île aucune maison n'est assuré
à cause de la structure foncière bien
spécifique de barbuda ici aucun habitant
n'a de titres de propriété simplement
une licence d'occupation car la terre ne
se vend pas c'est un bien collectif
toute la population de barbuda possède
la terre en commun tous ensemble nous
détenons la terre nous attribuons des
secteurs nous avons le droit dans
certains secteurs de construire nos
maisons d'avoir des activités
commerciales de comme des activités
agricoles
mais à cause de cette structure foncière
particulière nous ne pouvons pas obtenir
de crédit de près comme la plupart des
gens en ce qui me concerne pour
construire ma maison j'ai dû accumuler
des fonds faire ce que je peux jusqu'à
épuisement de cet argent puis économiser
à nouveau de l'argent essayer de
terminer sur le campus de l'université
américaine d'antigue les réfugiés de
barbuda débarquent des autobus affrété
spécialement par les autorités ils sont
tous invités à une rencontre avec le
gouvernement afin de discuter de leur
devenir
leeroy a fait le déplacement avec sa
compagne son fils sa fille et son père
tous impatients de rentrer chez eux
la rencontre fait salle comble et
s'annoncent houleux mais réfugiés
attendent des réponses rapides du chef
de gouvernement
nous sommes ici ce soir pour discuter de
votre retour gendarmes au delà et de la
reconstruction des routes
maintenant il est évident qu'en l'état
actuel barbuda est inhabitable
c'est indiscutable vous pouvez être sûr
qu'à la fin de cette crise d'ici à la
fin de l'année vous aurez de meilleures
infrastructures vous aurez un meilleur
port vous aurez un aéroport flambant
neufs des maisons et demi en emploi le
premier ministre promet monts et
merveilles pour faire passer la pilule
car il n'y aura pas de retour de la
population avant un nettoyage de l'île
prévue pour durer trois semaines
il prévoit également un délai minimum de
trois mois avant le rétablissement de
l'eau et de l'électricité calendrier cas
l'effet d'une douche froide pour
certains réfugiés
j'ai besoin d'aller immédiatement chez
moi pour nettoyer
nous devons réparer nous devons
restaurer nos maisons toutes nos maisons
notre communauté barbouille n personne
ne peut le faire à notre place
l'objectif c'est qu'au moins deux fois
par semaine nous permettions aux gens de
retourner pour diverses raisons
à cause de la façon dont les choses se
sont déroulées par le passé je suis très
sceptique
j'attends le moment où ces promesses
seront remplies
retour un barbuda pour le député de
l'île pour ce voyage à retenir cette
accompagné de quelques fonctionnel un
aller retour de quelques heures dans ce
petit avion spécialement affrété avec
l'état d'urgence aucun bar boudia ne
peut revenir sans autorisation direction
le seul hôpital de lille le représentant
parlementaire tient à nous montrer les
dégâts dont a souffert l'infrastructure
dans ses locaux dévastés et infestée de
moustiques plus possible aujourd'hui
d'accueillir des patients regarder
derrière moi ça c'est à la maison du
médecin
c'était le bâtiment d'un étage mais il a
été complètement détruit par l'ouragan
donc nous devons reconstruire il y à
l'hôpital qui est parti la maison du
docteur aussi au système de santé
vraiment dans le pétrin
[Musique]
dans la rue principale de caudry
m'etonnes voici tout ce qu'il reste du
bureau de poste
les locaux ont été totalement ravagées
[Musique]
nous retrouvons sur place cette femme
qui a fait le voyage pour une mission ou
bien spéciale
[Musique]
récupérez rapatrier antique des
documents précieux précédent les
décombres de ce bureau de poste
[Musique]
à l'intérieur nous avons des timbres et
des registres des documents comme les
testaments des gens qui font savoir leur
dernière volonté leur testament sont
donc enfermé dedans je prends maintenant
certains dossiers à emmener en tig
nous pourrons faire notre travail pour
ce secteur je prends le livre de caisse
je n'ai jamais vu quelque chose comme ça
de toute ma vie
vous savez quand l'ouragan est arrivé et
a tout écrasé
c'était horrible c'était horrible
expérience c'était la fois un cyclone un
tremblement de terre et une tornade
cette mission est l'occasion pour mérite
de se rendre rapidement chez elle elle
est accueillie sur le chemin par son
chien
trop heureux de revoir sa maîtresse
jusqu'ici tout va bien
juste un coup d'oeil on voit si tout est
intact
ce retour chez elle réveille les
souvenirs de l'événement terrifiant sa
maison a plutôt bien résisté mais une
fois la porte ouverte
une odeur pestilentielle nous prend au
nez c'est mon frigo
ça sent mauvais comme le courant est
coupé et que j'ai des choses dedans
c'est ça le problème
je suis très affligée j'ai vraiment mal
à l'estomac
[Musique]
cette catastrophe d'une ampleur inégalée
plonge les barbadiens dans une profonde
détresse
[Musique]
traumatisme aggravée par une évacuation
massive aux blessures du cyclone
s'ajoute la crainte de ne plus pouvoir
revenir chez soi
il faudra du temps pour panser les
plaies
[Musique]